[musique]
feu approprié
elle nous rap
il faut noter qu'il y a un incendie
la zone qui est touchée aujourd'hui
par le feu c'est vraiment très windows aussi
y compris pour la zone d'exclusion
centrale nucléaire de Tchernobyl et nous pouvons dire que
en général on peut dire que
probablement le plus grand incendie
approcher les incendies nucléaires et
l'objet dangereux de rayonnement est toujours
risque
mais dans ce cas il y a de l'espoir
le fait que la pluie de demain tout de même
contribue à éteindre cet incendie, mais
il est clair que le feu approche toujours
installation nucléaire traditionnelle
objets dangereux pour les rayonnements, il est toujours
risque et